other top story tonight staff within
ccsd are leaving in large numbers and
some telling us their frustration stems
from being overworked amid these recent
incidents of violence we've been telling
you about having their safety now in
jeopardy our victoria saha talked to one
teacher who says she already has one
foot out the door victoria david to give
you a better perspective of how many
teachers have left the district we
gathered some data at the end of 2020
school year we saw nearly 1400 teachers
leave then last year a big jump to
almost 1800 employees leaving and as of
a few weeks ago just over 1300 have
already separated from the district but
that number can increase as there is
still a month left in school a special
education teacher at crestwood asked us
to not show her face and alter her voice
so she doesn't get backlash for opening
up to us it's making me think like is
being a teacher worth it decades of
having a passion for teaching now coming
into question there's like no protection
for us our pay is not very good
it's more of a hassle to
do our jobs
we're given extra duties all the time
she tells us a key moment that made her
question her career was in december when
15 out of 40 teachers left leaving her
having to manage another class instead
of her special ed group my kids
got pushed to the side to add to that
violence against staff was increasing
they'll like punch you or hit you or
slap you and there's not really anything
you can do about it so you're not
feeling very safe in the building
there's no security to help you out in a
recent interview with superintendent dr
jarrah he admitted the district has been
severely understaffed for decades the
last time that we opened clark county
school district fully staffed 1994. to
address staff shortages the state now
only requires a high school diploma for
substitutes
that teacher you just heard from is
giving it one more chance to see if
anything does change and she is making
it her mission to uplift other teachers
who are there in a recent press
conference dr jarrah did address the
safety concerns saying they will give
panic buttons to every employee but he
wasn't sure exactly when david